SUBCOMMITTEE FOR AUSTIN
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WILL DISCUSS THE BUDGET THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD. EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
PROMINENT US RELATIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD.
SIMILAR LAST WEEK THE PLANS HERE
ALL ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
AND VOTE ON THESE ITEMS LATE IN
THE BUDGET SEASON.
RIGHT NOW WE A QUORUM SO START
OFF AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
HE MOVED TO ITEM NUMBER ONE.
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WRITTEN
NATION'S BOARD BUDGET OVERVIEW
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MARK
GERAGOS AND I'M THE CHAIR OF
UPPER. I'M JOINED TODAY ON MY
RIGHT WITH FELIX UP BY FELIX
DILATORY OUR GENERAL COUNSEL ON
MY LEFT MARIAN AGUAYO WHO IS
OUR.
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
PURPOSE BUDGET.
I KNOW IN YOUR AGENDA PACKET
THERE WERE SEVERAL QUESTIONS
AND.
I.
DEFERRED TO THE CHAIR IN TERMS
OF HOW YOU LIKE IT'S TO PROCEED
THAT WOULD BE GOOD IF YOU ASK
THE QUESTIONS OKAY SOUNDS GOOD
SO LET ME LET ME START AND I'LL
GIVE KIND OF A QUICK OVERVIEW
AND THEN WOULD ASK MY.
COLLEAGUES TO.
TO.
.
ADDRESS OF THINGS THAT I MIGHT
LEAVE OUT. OF FIRST FOR THE
CURRENT BACKLOG OF CASES IN PER
INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA PACKET
WORK TO GRAPHS THAT THE.
THAT REALLY LOOKED AT STAFFING
OF VACANCIES WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF THE GENERAL COUNSEL. AND WHAT
I'M CALLING SOME PRODUCTIVITY
INDICATORS IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF CASES CLOSE THE. AGE
OF CASES ON THE ON.
FACING THE.
GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
AS WELL AS THE NUMBER OF DAYS
THAT IT TOOK IN ORDER TO PROCESS
A CASE IN KIND OF GRAPH THAT
AGAINST THE VACANCIES.
AND WE WERE RUNNING AT WE HAD
SOME VACANCIES.
AND NOW WE'RE PRETTY MUCH
STAFFED UP.
AND SO.
WERE KIND OF REACHING A
BASELINE IN TERMS OF
PRODUCTIVITY WITH OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES THE AVERAGE AGE OF
CASES THAT ARE FACING. THE
OFFICE OF THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAYS.
WE ARE CLOSING IN A IN A
QUARTER ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE CASES.
AND THE NUMBER OF PENDING CASES
ARE AT THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE IS RUNNING SLIGHTLY OVER
FIVE HUNDRED CASES.
AND I SAY THAT'S OUR BASELINE AS
THAT'S
WHAT WERE.
UP PRODUCING BASED ON THE.
GIVEN RESOURCES THAT ARE
ALLOCATED I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT.
MY THE STATISTICS REFERRED TO
THE UP SENIOR THE UNFAIR
PRACTICE CHARGES WHICH IS ABOUT
SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE WORK
THAT'S FACING GENERAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
SO THAT'S SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
IN TERMS OF.
.
OUR GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE A
CASES THAT ARE PROCESS THE
GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND A
POTENTIAL YOUR APPEAL TO THE
OFFICE OF THE DIRECTOR OF A
POLICY REAL QUICK IT'S WOULD
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SURE. WE'VE
LOCAL POLICE COOPER HERE
OBERNOLTE HERE.
CHIU HERE CHOI.
THEY WE WITH WARM PLEASE
PROCEED.
CASES THAT ARE.
SCHEDULED FOR HEARING NOT OF
THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
THEN GO TO THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
AND THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
ADMINISTRATIVE.
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW IS
PRETTY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IT
HAS BEEN THERE RUNNING ABOUT
BETWEEN A HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND.
A HUNDRED AND TEN CASES AND
THAT'S KIND OF KIND OF THE
BASELINE.
THE NEXT STOP IN THE JOURNEY.
THROUGH OUR OUR ORGANIZATION
PER POTENTIALLY IS AT THE BOARD
LEVEL.
THE BOARD HAS HAD.
THREE THREE MEMBERS ON THE
BOARD.
AND RECENTLY THE GOVERNOR.
HAS APPOINTED A FULL BOARD SO
WE WILL HAVE FIVE BOARD MEMBERS.
.
AS OF APRIL NINTH WERE GOING TO
HAVE OUR FIFTH BOARD MEMBER AND
THAT'LL BE THE FIRST ON THE
BOARDS IN FULL AND HOW LONG.
.
YEAH FEBRUARY FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY SIXTEEN SO IT'S BEEN A
IT'S BEEN A COUPLE OF YEARS JUST
SO YOU CAN.
GET AN IDEA OF THE THE BOARDS
DOCKET RIGHT NOW WITH THREE
BOARD MEMBERS.
IT'S CURRENTLY EIGHTY ONE CASES
SO CURRENTLY EIGHTY ONE APPEAL
CASES ARE FACING THE BOARD
THAT'S APPROACHING AN ALL TIME
HIGH OF NINETY CASES THAT WE HAD
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. WHEN WE LAST HAD.
FIVE BOARD MEMBERS THE BOARD
STOCK IT WAS CONSIDERABLY
SMALLER IT WAS SIXTY OF ON THE
ONE THE BOARD STOCKETT.
SO THAT'S REALLY KIND OF A QUICK
SUMMARY OF.
THAT PRODUCTIVITY OF. ISSUES
AND THE STATUS OF FAR CASES THAT
ARE FACING THE BOARD AT AT ALL
LEVELS.
ANYTHING TO ADD.
MARION.
SO THE THE THE THE NEXT QUESTION
WAS.
RELATED TO BUDGET TRANSPARENCY
SHOWS THAT THERE WERE FUNDING OF
FOUR FOUR POINT FOUR POSITIONS
WERE BEING USED IN OTHER PLACES
WITHIN THE BUDGET.
THAT REALLY IS SALARY SAVINGS
WE WERE GENERATING A LOT OF
SALARY SAVINGS A BECAUSE OF THE
BOARD VACANCIES PRIMARILY AND WE
WERE INVESTING THAT I IN.
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF PER
PART OF THAT WAS USED TO REPLACE
OUR.
I THINK IT WAS NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE OUR CASEMENT WHICH WAS A
GOOD YEAR A.
THE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT
I BELIEVE WAS IMPLEMENTED THE IN
THE SEVENTIES WHO IS BEING
REPLACED.
THROUGH SOME OF THE SALARY
SAVINGS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
GENERATE IN ADDITION SOME COST
OVERRUNS WITH THE RELOCATION OF
OUR ALLEY OFFICE HAVE BEEN
FUNDED THROUGH THOSE SALARY
SAVINGS.
AND IN ADDITION WE WERE LOOKING
AT WAYS IN TERMS OF. INCREASING
STAFFING ON A TEMPORARY BASIS IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN.
DOING.
WITH THE WITH THE SALARY
SAVINGS.
ANY COMMENTS OR ADDITIONS.
THE NEXT QUESTION RELATED TO.
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTING THREE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO THE BOARD
HOW WILL THIS AFFECT THE BUDGET
I THINK THAT'S A CLASSIC GOOD
NEWS BAD NEWS SITUATION. THE
GOOD NEWS IS FIVE BOARD MEMBERS
WRITING DECISIONS ALONG WITH
LEGAL STAFF IS GOING TO INCREASE
THE BOARDS PRODUCTIVITY SO IS
GOING TO BE.
IT WILL BE ABLE TO CHIP AWAY AT
THE BACKLOG OF CASES THAT ARE
THAT THE APPOINTMENT OF THOSE
BOARD MEMBERS IS GOING TO DRY UP
THE SALARY SAVINGS THAT WE WERE.
A ONE TIME MONEY THAT WE WERE
USING TO INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PER.
TO. INCREASE OUR PRODUCTIVITY.
AND.
THE A AND AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO USE IT FOR EMPLOYEE
RETENTION WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
TURN OVER. A OF PURPOSE STAFF AS
THEY LOOK FOR PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO RETAIN.
DOES IT INDIVIDUALS AND WE'VE
ALSO USED SOME OF THAT SALARY
SAVINGS.
WERE INTENDED TO BE DEVOTED TO
THAT PARTICULAR PURPOSE.
THE FINAL QUESTION THAT'S ON
YOUR AGENDA HAS TO DO WITH.
THE TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT WERE ENACTED LAST YEAR AND
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IMPACT IS
THAT HAD.
ON PURPOSE WORKLOAD.
AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT IT
HASN'T BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD.
ONLY TIME WILL TELL.
NOW IT COULD HAVE AN INCREASED
IMPACT AWARD COULD ACTUALLY BE
LESS THAN THEM.
MODEST AMOUNT THAT WE'VE.
EXPERIENCED.
THUS FAR.
SO WITH THAT THAT KINDA
CONCLUDES ARE PREPARED RESPONSES
BEAT DELIGHTED TO HAVE RESPONDED
TO QUESTIONS SIR THANK YOU. S.
THIS FARCE RETENTION GOALS
WORRISOME YOUR CHALLENGES.
THE THE THE THE.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS
RETAINING A HIGH POWER OF
SEASONED REGIONAL ATTORNEYS.
THE PROMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN PROBE ARE LIMITED.
AND.
SOME OF OUR REGIONAL ATTORNEYS
WHO LOVE THE WORKING FOR PER.
ARE SEEK PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITY AND ARE
TRANSFERRING.
TO OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS
SO THEY'RE STAYING WITHIN THIS
STATE SYSTEM.
WHICH IS A GOOD THING BECAUSE
WERE ROOF RETAINING A LOT OF
EXCELLENT TALENT BUT THE. THE
UNFORTUNATE THING IS THAT'S NOT
WITH PER.
AND WE'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE THE THE ARE ANALYSIS
INDICATES THAT.
THE MORE EXPERIENCE ATTORNEYS
ARE ACTUALLY TURNING OUT A
HIGHER NUMBER OF CASES THEN THE.
AND.
THEN THE NEW ATTORNEYS.
AND WE'D LIKE TO RETAIN THAT
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY IN THE
SENIOR ATTORNEYS THE ATTORNEYS
ARE TRANSFERRING EARLY TRANSFER
INTO HIGHER PAYING JOBS YES
BILLS FROM THE STATE YES I I IT
AND. NOT ONLY HIGH HIGHER PAYING
JOBS WITH SUMMER LATERALLY IN
INTO LARGER AGENCIES TO.
OF FROM A STRATEGIC STANDPOINT
IN ORDER TO.
OPEN UP OTHER PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
SO YOU NEED MORE MONEY.
IF THAT'S A.
AND. IT IS.
WELL YOU KNOW I THAT I THINK IS
AS I DESCRIBED OUR OUR BASELINE
IS OUR BASELINE I MEAN THE THE
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT.
.
IT'S TAKEN US A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DAYS AT THE GENERAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE IN ORDER TO
CLEAR OUT CASES AND WE'VE GOT.
A BACKLOG OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
CASES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WERE EAM AND
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD AND SO
THAT'S THE BASELINE THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES.
IF WE GOT MORE RESOURCES.
WE'D BE ABLE TO CHIP AWAY AT.
SOME OF THOSE BACKLOGS.
OKAY ELLIOTT.
FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
OKAY WHICH OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO HARD
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE BACKLOG OF
CASES AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT
SEVERAL BILLS LAST YEAR THAT
WERE SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
CREATE EVEN MORE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOU IF IF YOU
NEED MORE MONEY FOR.
FURTHER AIR I HEAD COUNT AND
TRAINING WHY HAVE YOU NOT COME
FORWARD WITH THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL TO ASK FOR THAT MONEY.
YES.
NPR THE TWO PROPOSALS THAT CAME
ACROSS LAST YEAR WEREN'T.
.
UP PROPOSALS THAT PRODUCED A LOT
OF EXTRA WORK TO WORK WERE
TALKING ABOUT HAS BEEN PRE
EXISTING WHAT WE'VE HAD THESE
BACKLOG PROBLEMS NOW SINCE I'VE
ARRIVED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AND THEY'VE BEEN THE FOCUS OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
THROUGH VARIOUS INITIATIVES BUT
THE TO PROPOSAL YOU'RE SPEAKING
OF THE PCC IN THE ORIENTATION
BILL. THEMSELVES ROB ONLY
INCREASED A WORKER VERY
MARGINALLY.
OKAY SO I THINK WE WOULD ALL BE
UNIFIED OUR OPINION THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO GET THE BACKLOG
REDUCED.
SO HOW DO WE GO ABOUT DOING
THAT.
WELL I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IN FIGURE OUT PAYS A ARE
A WAY OF ON STRUCTURING PURPOSE
SO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO RETAIN
OUR ATTORNEYS.
BE MORE EFFICIENT IN FACT I'M
AM IN MARKET SPEAK MORE TO THIS
BUT THE BOARD ITSELF HAS.
INITIATED A CASE PROCESSING IT
INITIATIVE INITIATIVE THAT'S
LOOKING AT WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR
CASE PROCESSING THROUGH OTHER
WAYS.
THAT DON'T REQUIRE THE BCP BUT.
WHERE WHERE DEFERENCE
FLORENTIUS OPTIONS?
OKAY LET'S BUT HERE I MEAN WE
WANT TO BE YOUR PARTNERS IN
GETTING THAT BACK LOAD REDUCED
AND OBVIOUSLY. IF WE CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT COMMITTING ADDITIONAL
STATE RESOURCES THERE THAT THAT
EVERYBODY WINS BUT.
IF WE TRY AND WE FAIL THEM YOU
KNOW REALLY WE EVERYBODY HAS
LOST SO YOU KNOW WHAT US KNOW
HOW WE CAN BE YOUR PARTNERS INTO
IT.
YEAH I THINK JUST COUPLE WORDS
ON THE CASE PROCESS INITIATIVE
THE BOARD DID GO THROUGH A VERY
EXTENSIVE PROCESS MEETING WITH
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND EMPLOYEES
AND CAME UP WITH A REPORT THAT
INCLUDED A NUMBER OF. ITEMS
THAT.
POTENTIALLY COULD IMPROVE THE
PROCESSING OF.
OF OF CASES THAT A REPORT IS.
ON OUR WEBSITE.
AVAILABLE.
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
WILL BE THE SUBJECT OF MEETINGS
PUBLIC MEETINGS OF THE BOARD
TOMORROW AND THURSDAY DOWN IN
LA.
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN TERMS OF WHICH OF THOSE HAS
PRIORITIES SO? YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART.
ARE ALTHOUGH THE.
THOSE SUGGESTIONS EVEN OF ALL
OF THEM ARE IMPLEMENTED WOULD
NOT REALLY APPRECIABLY ADDRESS.
THE THEIR APPROACH CASE BACKLOG.
ALRIGHT WELL I WANT TO BE
OPTIMISTIC BUT GIVEN THE HISTORY
OF THE BACKLOG IT'S HARD TO BE
OPTIMISTIC AND I JUST HOPE WE
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN GET
THAT BACKLOG REDUCED.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
YOU HEALTH FIND NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES NOW OBVIOUSLY IF YOU.
TRY AND WORKS OF THINGS AROUND
US IN RESULT STILL THE SAME.
YOU'RE LIMITED AND THEN YOU MADE
UP YOU MADE OUT PUT IN FOR OR
ASK FOR ANY BCP'S BUT.
I GUESS MY QUESTION HAVE YOU
MADE REQUEST INTERNAL IN.
OBVIOUSLY MENTAL NOT TO PUT HIM
FOR THOSE REQUEST FORWARD.
WISHED IS KNOWING HOW STATE
WORKS IT HAS AS ITS FIELD SAID
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
OPERATIONAL ISSUES BUT AT HAVE
YOU ASKED.
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
NOT TO BE CP'S AND THAT'S MY
QUESTION TO YOU LIVE IN A FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
AWARE OF OUR STAFFING THAT MEAN
WE ARE LABOR INTENSIVE
ORGANIZATION THE MORE STAFF WE
HAVE THE. MORE CASES THAT WE CAN
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH FINANCE
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS HOUSE A
GREAT. WALK AROUND TOPIC THAT AS
A YES. YEAH THAT'S THAT'S THE
SAD PART ABOUT IT IS QUITE OFTEN
IS AGENCIES THEY'RE ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL BODIES ARE RESOURCES
AND. NO SON NEEDED SOME NOT
NEEDED BUTTON THERE TOLD HER YOU
CAN'T PUT A MAN
SO I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
IN THE WAY THE CITY WORKS WHICH.
SEEMS KINDA CONTRARY BUT ANYWAY
THE WHOLE AND OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ISSUE.
ALONG WITH CASTRO FIRM.
TO CHECK COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MICHELLE CASTER OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
DESPITE A PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF.
DEMOCRATIC CONTEXT AND
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW.
HERB GOT TO SUCH A LEVEL SUCH
BIG BACKLOG.
THE BOARD HAS BEEN UNDERFUNDED
AS LONG AS ANY OF US CAN
REMEMBER BUT THE PROBLEM WAS
REALLY EXACERBATED IN TWO
THOUSAND. UMPIRE TO TWO THOUSAND
THE BOARD. ADMINISTERED ENFORCED
THREE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAWS
COVERING ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION EMPLOYEES. IN TWO
THOUSAND SB SEVEN THREE NINE WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW THAT PUT THE
MYERS MILIUS BROWN ACT UNDER THE
BOARD. AND WHAT THAT IS ADDED
THREE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED MORE
EMPLOYERS IN APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT THREE MORE ON THREE POINT
ONE POINT THREE MILLION MORE
EMPLOYEES. AT THAT TIME A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST WAS MADE TO BOB FOR
THEIR BUDGET TO ACCOMMODATE THE
ADDITIONAL WORK.
BUT INSTEAD TO ONLY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WAS PUT INTO THE BUDGET
SINCE THEN ANOTHER FORMER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ACCIDENT
ADDED TO.
PURPOSE RESPONSIBILITIES YET
THEY'VE ONLY HAD MINOR
ADJUSTMENTS HERE AND THERE.
.
AS NOTED IN ANALYSIS PURP WAS
GIVEN MORE.
LA. RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
BILL'S LAST YEAR AND YES I'VE
ONLY.
SEEN VERY MINOR CHANGES BUT THE
LOT REALLY HASN'T BEEN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED YET SO WE JUST DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO COME OUT OF
THAT.
.
WE HOPE THAT THIS BODY WOULD.
AUGMENT THEIR BUDGET BY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON SO THEY CAN
PROCESS CASES FASTER THAN THE
HUNTER APPROXIMATE HUNDRED FIFTY
DAYS.
HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS IS ABOUT FIVE
MONTHS IF YOU HAVE A COMPLAINT
FIVE MONTHS LATER YOUR COMPLAINT
MIGHT BE MOVED.
SO REALLY MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE PARTIES TO GET ANY KIND
OF ITEM. JUSTICE A REDRESS ONE
THE BACKLOG IS SO.
SO DEEP SO WE WOULD.
REALLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE BOARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S
MICHAEL YA ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION.
WE AGREE WITH EVERYTHING CHAU
CASHEL.
ALLUDED TO AND WE ALSO AGREE
WITH YOUR LINE OF QUESTIONING
THE SOLUTION HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT PARK HAS MORE MONEY
THEY HAVE ANYMORE STAFF MEMBERS
TO BE ABLE TO PROCESS THESE
CLAIMS THAT MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
MORE COST EFFECTIVELY.
.
MORE MORE AT THE PER BOARD IS
GOING TO BE A ESSENTIAL IN TERMS
OF AYE DEALING WITH GROUP
DISPUTES THE WORKPLACE IN TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
HAS A HARMONIOUS RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN. BOTH EMPLOYER EMPLOYEES
DUH THE LENGTH OF THESE BACKLOGS
JUST GROWING BY TOO MUCH LENGTH.
BETWEEN WHICH THESE DISPUTES
ARE BEING HERS IS GROWING BY TOO
LONG AND MORE AND MORE WORKERS
ARE VIEWING CURVE AS.
AS IN SUCCESSFUL OPTION IN
RESOLVING THESE DISPUTES.
SO. IT'S OUR OPINION THAT.
THIS BODY SHOULD CONSIDER.
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER GIVING HER
MORE MONEY OUR RECOMMENDATION
IS.
AGAIN FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING AUGMENTATION SUPERB TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE STAFFING
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR PUBLIC WORKERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISSY
BAUM ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
I'VE BEEN STANDING HERE BEFORE
YOU BEFORE SAYING THE SAME
THINGS I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING MAYBE
THE QUESTION MORE IS ARE YOU
FULLY RESOURCE AS AN AGENCY IN
ORDER MEET.
NOT JUST THE STATUTORY MANDATES
BECAUSE YOU WON'T BE ALARMED TO
FIND THAT THERE AREN'T ANY WITH
RESPECT TO TIME LINES SO.
CAN YOU MEET THE POLICY MANDATES
THE INTENT OF THE ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION TO RESOLVE CASES
QUICKLY.
IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH FIVE YEARS
OR SEVEN YEARS THAN THEIR
MEETING THEIR STATUTORY MIND
MANDATES BECAUSE THERE ARE NONE.
A MAN I WOULD ONLY ADD THAT THE
THE CASE PROCESSING EFFICIENCIES
PROJECT THE BOARD UNDERWENT.
THEY DID DO AN AMAZING JOB
SOLICITING IMPACT FROM
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND DEVELOPED
AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF THINGS THEY
COULD DO TO IMPROVE THEIR
OPERATIONS AND GUESS WHAT NEARLY
ALL OF THEM HAVE A LITTLE STAR
BY THEM THAT SAYS. AND THIS ALL
WILL COST US MORE MONEY.
SO WELL MAYBE THERE HASN'T BEEN
A FORTHCOMING REQUEST OR AT
LEAST THAT HAS MADE IT ALL THE
WAY OUT TO THE PUBLIC VIEW WE
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER AN
AUGMENTATION AS DESCRIBE BY MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PURPOSE BUDGET. SO
THEY CAN DO THE JOB THAT THEY'RE
SIGNED TO DO WHICH IS TO CREATE
LABOR PEACE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR JAN MEMBERS
JOSH WILL WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
FOR ALL OF THE REASONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES STATED ASKED ME WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST AN
AUGMENTATION OF AT LEAST FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
PRECONDITION THIS INFORMATION
NOT ONLY.
SOME OF ONTO OUR NEXT ITEM.
NUMBER TWO IS A PLUMBER
DEVELOPMENT APARTMENT BENEFIT
SYSTEM MOBILIZATION EVER SEES
THE MODERNIZATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
NAME'S PATRICK CUTTING THEM THE
DIRECTOR THE PLYMOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. OF ONE
OF THE THANK YOU FOR.
ENTERTAINING OUR.
BUDGET PASS.
LOVE AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
APPROXIMATELY.
FOUR YEARS AGO OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM AT THE DEPARTMENT FAILED
TO.
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS.
OUT TO CALIFORNIANS.
BUT GOING THROUGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE GONE
THROUGH A NUMBER OF A DIFFERENT
SMALLER TECHNICAL PROJECTS TO
BRING US UP TO SPEED AT THE
DEPARTMENT. OF WHICH ALL.
IN THE WAY ENDED UP BEING A
BAND AID APPROACH AS WE CONTINUE
TO TRY TO KEEP PART SYSTEM.
AFLOAT THAT AND MOVING.
BUT THIS THAT PROJECT REFLECTS
THE THE DEPARTMENT'S DESIRE TO
REPLACE THE BENEFIT SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS THAT SCOOP IN THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM. THAT THEY
CURRENTLY ARE.
NOT MODERNIZE TO A LEVEL THAT
IS SUFFICIENT UP BY I WOULD
IMAGINE ANYBODY STANDARDS.
DOES THIS AUGMENTATION IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE PROJECT THE
PROJECT IS GOING VERY WELL. THAT
WE HAVE A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
WITH.
OUR.
TECHNICAL DEPARTMENT.
TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT AS WELL
TEHAMA FINANCING GOOD SUPPORT
FROM.
OR LABOR AGENCY AS WELL.
LL.
FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
A LOT OF UP PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
CAL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
YEAH WE'RE HOMELESS OPEN.
SO THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM IS THIS NUMBER THREE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF S. B. THREE
NINE SIX MAYBE SIX SEVEN SEVEN.
EMPLOYMENT GENDER IDENTITY AND
DATA COLLECTION.
THIS IS A GENERALLY A FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM.
THE ADJUSTMENTS.
THAT ARE MADE I'VE JUST REFLECT
OF BARGAINING AND ADJUSTMENTS.
OF FROM THE LAST GO AROUND.
AND THIS JUST IN ADDITION
REQUEST WHO WE CAN PUT THIS IN
PLACE.
LL.
FINANCE.
IF YOU.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR YOUR CONTINUED
FOCUS ON THIS AS THE AUTHOR OF
AB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN ON ENSURING
THAT UP. AGUIAR IMPROPERLY
COLLECTING GENDER IDENTITY.
DATA AND THE IMPLEMENT ON TEXAN
LOOK FOR THIS WORK CONTINUED
GREAT. THANK YOU.
I WANT UP A PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE OCEANS BECOME THIS ITEM UP
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OTHER CONDITIONS TO ALL THIS
ITEM OPENS WILL OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
FESTIVALS ON BEFORE OCTOBER
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS.
ALTHOUGH WE WILL BONE WITH THE
WAY.
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON
THIS.
THAT WE HAVE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
AND THESE ARE. A LITTLE TWEAKS
AND CHANGES THAT HELP US. A
CONTINUE ON THE GOOD WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
CAN YOU DISCUSS THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL AUGMENTATION.
WE HAVE SOME REPRESENTS FROM
POINT A TRADING HAVE APPEARED TO
ADDRESS UP.
INCLUDING THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BOARD.
STARBUCKS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AN
ELF AUTHOR OF COOPER A MAIL
FOR INCLUDED TRAINING PANEL.
DID YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THE AUGMENTATION
THE TEN MILLION OR.
PLUS TALK ABOUT THE AUGMENTATION
IN WHAT WAS GOING TO SURE
ABSOLUTELY.
SO.
CURRENTLY.
WE HAVE ABOUT.
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
CONTRACTS OF THERE HELD. IN WITH
ABOUT NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING LEFT LOOK FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR SO CURRENTLY.
WERE AT CAPACITY.
THIS WOULD ADD CAPACITY FOR THIS
NEXT FISCAL YEAR ADDING ABOUT
FOLLOWED ALMOST FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR US. MOVING INTO A
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SO DOUBTS ABOUT ALL OF US FOR
HER NEW CONTRACTS TRENES ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND.
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT TEN MILLION DOLLAR
OBLIGATION
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
CALVET A PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE
WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM. OKL
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION.
IS ALWAYS OPEN.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM IS USE NUMBER FIVE.
THE PRESSURE PROGRAM FOR
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRIES
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE I AM
JANET SOUTH CHIEF OF STAFF OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS. THE
BCP YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
AIMS TO INCREASE PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET WORKFORCE
NEEDS IN THREE AREAS
NONTRADITIONAL BUILDING TRADE
INDUSTRY SUCH AS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING AND HEALTH CARE IN
ADDITION I THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CIVIL SERVICE
AND UP FOR INMATES AND EX
OFFENDERS. WE HAVE MADE SOME
PROGRESS IN THESE AREAS HOWEVER
AS WE'VE SEEN IN YEARS PAST WILL
WE DO A INITIAL SPUR. DENISE TO
BE A SYSTEMIC WAY TO MAINTAIN
PEAKS INITIAL SUCCESS TO. THE UP
THE GOAL OF DOT AYE DOUBLING THE
AMOUNT OF FRIENDSHIP BY TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN.
WELL.
GILES ALMOST LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE'VE REVIEWED
THE PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO
SPECIFIC CONSISTENT.
FINANCE.
MARK MANAGED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS.
IT QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
IT REAL QUICK THE A TWENTY
SEVEN.
TEAM BUDGET ACT WHETHER SIX
POSITIONS ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
GRANT.
THIS PROPOSALS A BIGGER PIECE OF
THE CURRENT YEAR.
AL DEPARTMENT MEASURE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXCELLENT
QUESTION SO I'M OF COURSE WE
DIDN'T NEED TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A PRO ACTIVE ON BOARDING
PROCESS IN PLACE HOWEVER WE HAVE
SPECIFIC METRICS FOR.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A WAY TO
COUNT THE NUMBERS OF PROGRAMS
NEW PROGRAMS IN EACH OF THE
SECTORS THAT WOULD DESCRIBE. AS
WELL AS.
ONBOARDING APPRENTICES IN THOSE
AREAS.
PRETTY THING VERY MUCH FINANCE.
THE ILLEGAL.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SEEN NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WILL
PROCEED TO THE NEXT ITEM.
WILL GOTO ISSUE SIX.
FROM THE APARTMENT.
THANK YOU SIR MY NAME IS GOING
TO WERE TIME THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF.
WE'RE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND JOINING
ME.
AT THE TABLE WILL BE.
LIST YOU ISSUE SUSHI IS THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
THE THIS PROPOSAL.
IS TO AUGMENT THE ADVIL IS FEES.
HEADQUARTERS OPERATION
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREAS OF
RECRUITMENT  ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THAT ADDED SEVERAL POSITIONS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WITH
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ARE. SLATED
TO.
pNINETEEN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
YEARS AS PART OF A THREE YEAR
PHASE AND.
OF THE INCREASE TO THE BUREAU
OF FIELD ENFORCEMENT THESE
RESOURCES WILL HELP THE
DEPARTMENT. A CONTINUE TO
SUSTAIN ITS PROGRESS IN FILLING
VACANCIES AND.
FURTHER PREPARE TO AYE IMPROVE
ON THAT PROGRESS NOW SO THIS IS
VERY MUCH ABOUT RICK RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. AND HELPING TO
SUPPORT OF THE OPERATIONAL NEEDS
OF OF THE DIVISION.
I DON'T COMMISSIONER.
IT IS CO WAS GOING TO ASK A HOW
IMPORTANT.
THIS EXPENDITURE WAS BUT I I
THINK GIVEN THE PRESENCE THE
COMMISSION HERE OF MY KISSES YOU
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN AS.
MISTER EDWARDS HAS MENTIONED
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR AND HAPPY
ABOUT THE B. C. PIECE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN GRANTED TO AUGMENT OUR
STAFF IN ORDER TO BEAT THE
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS. UP TO FIGHT
WAGE THEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS A WE NEED WE SEE ALSO THE
NEED NOT JUST FOR THE FRONT LINE
ENFORCEMENT FOLKS BUT ALSO FOR.
PEOPLE IN THE ADMIN SITE TO
HELP SUPPORT THIS TREMENDOUS
GROWTH TO.
DEAL WITH THE HIRING THE
RECRUITMENT THE ON BOARDING THE
TRAINING.
THE PERSONNEL MANAGEMENT THAT
COMES UP SOME OF THE FACILITIES.
OFFICE SPACE ISSUES ALL OF THAT
ARE OBVIOUSLY THE MORE YOUR
STAFF GROWS THE MORE THOSE NEEDS
GROW AND THIS PC PS BUT TO
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. GREAT THANK
YOU FINANCE.
ELIOT.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT OUR
TRADE WITH ACTIVE CHAIR BUT IT'S
JUST A QUESTION HAPPEN VIA
PEORIA QUESTION GROWN SO MUCH.
I MEAN THAT IS YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT I CAN ONLY
SPECULATE ABOUT.
BUT WE DEFTLY HAVE SEEN A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE USE OF
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST TO
ASK ANYTHING FROM TIME LINES
THAT WE HAVE ON THE KINDS OF
CASES THAT WE'RE THAT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. A WE GET QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR STAFFING OF THERE'S
JUST BEEN A TREMENDOUS GROWTH
AND INTEREST IN A IN IN THE WORK
OF THE DIVISION.
AND WHAT WE GET WE HAVE
STRUGGLED FRANKLY TO MEET THE
STATUTORY A REQUIREMENT TO
RESPOND WITHIN A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF DAYS UNQUALIFIED AND NUMBER
OF HOURS USE BIZZARE DOLLAR
AMOUNT. ASSOCIATE WITH THAT
ALSO.
EVEN SORT OF STAFF TIME YET
SPEND YES.
BUT THE TWO POINT.
TO POINT OUT TWO POINT TWO FIVE
HOURS PER REQUEST.
SO OBVIOUSLY FOUR THOUSAND HOURS
A YEAR.
RIGHT I GUESS WEEK WE I'M SO
SORRY.
CHAIRMAN OF I DON'T HAVE THAT
IN FRONT OF ME BUT WE COULD DO
THE MATH ON THAT OBVIOUSLY RIGHT
WE COULD TAKE THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT. STAFF USES TO DO
EVERYTHING FROM COLLECTING
INFORMATION REDACTING IT
PRESENTING IT.
AND IT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TAKEN AWAY
FROM HOUSING WAGE CLAIMS THAT
INVESTIGATING.
SCOFFLAWS EMPLOYERS AND
ENSURING THAT RETALIATION IS NOT
HAPPENING TO COLLECT A THESE
KINDS OF RECORDS SO.
I DON'T I I DON'T HAVE THAT
FIGURE BUT.
I CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT MATH I
THINK OF THE BENEFICIAL FOR YOUR
FOR YOURSELF SO YEAH BECAUSE YOU
COULD.
GET THAT OUT FOR US.
SO THANK YOU OF.
THE PUBLIC ALREADY RIGHT. WE
HAVE.
AND WISHED ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM.
CHEMICALS PUBLIC COMMENT
REPETITIONS ALWAYS OPEN SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT MOVE AUDITION EVER SEVEN.
SCHOOLS OCCUPATIONAL INJURY AND
ILLNESS PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
SOME OF THIS PROPOSAL ARM WILL.
ALBEIT THE DIVISION SO FUNDING
FOR A LIMITED TERM I'M ONLY TERM
BASIS FOR THREE YEARS OUGHT TO
HELP SCHOOLS IMPLEMENT. IT
INJURY AND ILLNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
.
THE SOURCE OF THIS FUNDING.
A COMES FROM.
WHEN SCHOOLS ARE CITED.
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ABATE THAT CITATION AND WHEN
THEY DO THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REQUEST.
THE RETURN OF THOSE FUNDS.
THE LABOR COAL PROVIDES A
PROVISION FOR THE USE OF THOSE
DOLLARS IF THE MONEY IS NOT
REQUESTED TO BE RETURNED.
THEN THAT THIS MONEY IS TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR GRANTS FOR
THIS VERY PURPOSE
AND SO IT TAKES A LITTLE WHILE
FOR THE FUNDS TO ACCUMULATE
THEY'VE DONE SO. THIS IS
PROBABLY THIS THIRD SECOND OR
THIRD TIME THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR
A ONE TIME AUGMENTATION OF FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
MS REVOLVING FUND HAVE TO REACH
A CERTAIN LEVEL BEFORE THE FUNDS
CAN BE USED.
THAT NOT NECESSARILY BUT BUT
THE FUNDS TRICKLE IN IN THAT
SPORADIC WAY. AND SCHOOLS WHO
ARE ARE CITED IN HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY A TO ABATE THEY HAVE
SO MANY YEARS IN ORDER TO PUT IN
THE REQUEST SO WE HAVE TO WAIT.
FOR THAT TIME COLLAPSE.
AND BEFORE WE KNOW THAT THOSE
FUNDS COULD NOW BE FREED UP AND
AVAILABLE FOR THIS PURPOSE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ELIDEL.
FINANCE.
A PUBLIC COMMENT NOTION SPEAK.
KILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WRITTEN DIGITAL THIS ITEM OPEN
SOLD OPEN THANK YOU.
WE GOT ISSUED EVER EIGHT VICTIMS
OF WAGE THEFT.
SO THIS OP PROPOSAL IS ABOUT
TAKING ON MONEY FROM THE UNPAID
WAIT FUND WHICH IS MONIES THAT
HAVE BEEN COLLECTED ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS WHO WERE NOT PAID WHAT
THEY SHOULD'VE BEEN PAID. BUT
THE WORKERS COULD NOT BE FOUND
SO FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
WHATEVER THE REASONS ARE THE
WORKERS CANNOT DIRECTLY BE STEVE
THE MONEY SO MONEY GOES INTO
UNPAID WAGE UND. OUR REQUEST IS
TO ACTUALLY TAKE THAT MONEY
INSTEAD OF HAVING IT GOING TO
THE GENERAL FUND AFTER CERTAIN
P. OF TIME IN WHICH IT'S NOT
CLAIMED. HAVE YOU GO TO ANY ONE
OF OUR RESTITUTION FUNDS AND WE
HAVE BY STATUTE THREE
RESTITUTION FUNDS THAT HELP TO
SERVE THE LOWEST PAID WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S
A FARM WORKER RESTITUTION FUND.
CAR WASH RESTITUTION FUND AND A
GARMENT INDUSTRY RESTITUTION
FUND AND WHAT HAPPENS THERE IS
ANY WORKER IN THOSE INDUSTRIES
WHO PROVE THAT THEIR WAGES ARE
HAVE BEEN STOLEN AND THAT THAT
WE JUST OWE TO THEM SO THE
WORKERS HAVE COME FORWARD.
USUALLY THEY'VE GONE THROUGH OUR
WAGE CLAIM PROCESS MAYBE WE'VE
DONE A BOTH THE INVESTIGATION TO
FIND THAT THERE THAT THEY WERE
UNDERPAID. AND THEY HAVE A FINAL
JUDGEMENT FOR WAGES THEY IF
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO GO GET
THE MONEY THE EMPLOYER HAS
ABSCONDED CLOSE SHOP.
THEN THEY CAN GO THE
RESTITUTION FUND TO GET THEIR
MONEY AND CURRENTLY THOSE FUNDS
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
CLAIMS ON THEM JUST AS THE
EXAMPLE OF FOR THE IN THE
GARMENT FUND.
WE'VE HAD MADE OVER FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN CLAIMS
BY GARMENT WORKERS WHO HAVE WE
JUDGMENTS.
TO THOSE FUNDS AND A SINCE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THERE HAS NOT
BEEN SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO PAY
THEM OUT SO WE'D LIKE TO DO IS
TAKE MONEY. THAT BELONGS TO SOME
WORKERS WHO CAN'T GET NOTIFIED
AND TRACK THEM TO FUNDS WERE THE
WILL GO TO OTHER WORKERS WHO WHO
HAD BEEN IDENTIFIED IN WHO WERE
AWAITING THEIR HARD EARNED
WAGES.
OKAY HOW MUCH FUNDING DOES THE
UNPAID WHICH PHONE RECEIVE EVERY
YEAR.
OF THE AVERAGE A COMING INTO THE
UNPAID WAGE FUND FOR THE LAST
THREE TO FOUR YEARS HAS VARIED
BETWEEN THREE MILLION AND SIX
MILLION A YEAR.
SO THIS IS A ONE TIME REQUEST TO
A DIVERT SOME OF THAT FUNDING.
PRIOR TO TRANSFER TO THE GENERAL
FUND TO THESE WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED SO THERE ARE
ACTUAL WORKERS WE HAVE ACTUAL
CLAIMS THAT WE ARE HOLDING.
BECAUSE OF INSUFFICIENT FUNDS IN
THE GARMENT RESTITUTION. AND
WATER COMES FROM FUNDS COME
FROM.
OF THAT THE SOURCE OF THE MONEY
IS.
AND MAYBE YOU CAN.
ELABORATE ON THAT JUST. WHAT
WILL THE SOURCE OF THE MONEY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS FROM
OTHER PAYMENTS IN OTHER CASES TO
WORKERS SO FOR EXAMPLE WE MAY
HAVE?
A CASE IN ANYINDUSTRY WHERE
THE EMPLOYER WAS FOUND TO OWE
WAGES.
BUT OFTENTIMES ESPECIALLY IN
THESE MULTIPLE INDUSTRIES THE
WORKERS ARE NOT AVAILABLE AT THE
TIME THAT THAT THE JUDGMENT IS
MADE AND THE PAYMENT IS MADE.
AND SO ONCE THE EMPLOYER AND WE
DO IT DAR DO DILIGENCE TO FIND
OUT WE CANNOT THAT MONEY IS
STILL PAID BY THE EMPLOYER BUT
IT DOESN'T GO TO. THE THE
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THERE ANYMORE SO THAT SO THAT'S
WHERE THAT GOES THE GOES INTO
UNPAID WAIT FUN BUT GENERALLY
THE RESTITUTION FUND MONEY COMES
FROM. PAYMENTS MADE BY EMPLOYERS
IN THOSE INDUSTRIES WHEN THEY
REGISTER SO PORTION OF THE
REGISTRATION FEE GOES INTO THIS
RESTITUTION FUND AND WE'RE JUST
FINE THAT THAT AMOUNT IS NOT
ENOUGH TO MEET THE. DEMANDS OF
WORKERS FOR UNPAID WAGES.
THANK YOU BELIAU.
DLF.
WELL LET'S BREAK IT IS THE AND
IT'S STILL GOING BACK TO VICTIMS
SO THAT'S THE YOU KNOW WHEN WE
ANOTHER. WERE STILL BEING
SOMEONE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN
WRONG.
ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
OKAY A CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS ALL THIS
ITEM OPEN.
SO WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS A SHAME NUMBER NINE
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ISSUE
NUMBER NINE.
IS A COLLECTION OF THREE. OF
BILLS THAT WERE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
.
THESE REQUESTS ASK FOR RESOURCES
TO ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT I
HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT OF THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION.
A ONE FOUR PRETTY SHIP TRAINING
FUNDS GRANT THAT IS TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADEQUATELY OVERSEE. GRANT TEAMS
WHO HAVE RECEIVED MONEY FOR
PRETTY SHIP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SPENDING OF THAT MONEY
APPROPRIATELY OKAY. ARMED.
ITEM NUMBER TWO US UP THERE AND
WAS AT OVERSIGHT CONSIST OF
POLITICS.
OUR OUR AUDITING OF THEIR
PROGRAMS.
OF MAKING SURE OF THAT.
THEY HAVE SPENT THE MONEY.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THROUGH THE
STIPULATIONS OF THE GRANTS
WHATEVER THOSE GRANTS MAY BE BUT
ALSO I'M THERE ARE A SEVERAL.
STATUTORY OR REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ALL THE PRETTY
SHIP PROGRAMS FOR QUALITY THE
STANDPOINT NEED TO MEET JUST TO
INSURE THAT THOSE APPRENTICES
WHO ARE RECEIVING THE SERVICE.
OUR ARE ARE RECEIVING.
THOUGH THE FULL SUPPORT OF THE
EMPLOYER I. IN THAT REGARD
BESIDES DO THE PAPER AUDIT
OBVIOUSLY DO THEY ACTUALLY GO
OUT AND VISIT THOSE SITES THAT
YES LIGHTS YEAH IT'S NOT JUST A
PAPER ON IDIOTS. IT ENTAILS A
SITE VISIT
ARE TALKING TO OF THE ACTUAL UP
PARTICIPANTS OF THE PROGRAM
REVIEWING THEIR RECORD SIDE OF
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
IF YOU.
LL.
FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER TRIP.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
I THINK THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FOR WORK TOGETHER NAY BEFORE
FIFTY AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
IMMIGRANT WORKER. PROTECTION
ACT.
WHILE I WAS THE AUTHOR WE
RECEIVED A SIGNIFICANT INPUT AND
FEEDBACK IN LEADERSHIP FROM.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER AND HER
STAFF AND I VERY MUCH SUPPORT.
THIS BUDGET ASK WHICH WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED AND CERTAINLY
THIS PAST WEEK WITH THE VISIT TO
CALIFORNIA OF THE US ATTORNEY. A
GENERAL.
SESSIONS ARE SUGGESTING THAT
THIS IS NOT AN AREA OF THAT THEY
ARE INTERESTED IN ITS MORE
IMPORTANT EVER THAT WE THAT WE
STEP AND AND. DO WE NEED TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR ECONOMY IS
NOT UNDERMINED BY THE ACTIONS OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. ARE
AND THAT ARE IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE
IS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
FOR COMPANIES IN INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE SUCCEEDED BECAUSE OF ITS OF
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN CHU THIS
THIS UP ON A BEFORE FIFTY IT IS
A REQUEST FOR STAFFING TO
ENFORCE THESE PROVISIONS THAT.
PLACE IT REQUIREMENTS ON
EMPLOYERS WHEN ICE COMES TO DO
AN INVESTIGATION UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND THE
EMPLOYEES ARE.
PROTECTED AND THAT THE THE.
WORKPLACE SAFETY.
IS ALL IS ALSO UP PRIORITIZED
OUT WHEN ICE CHOOSES A WHERE TO
DO ITS INVESTIGATIONS.
THANK YOU.
WELL ATTRACT.
ARE YOU FINANCING WELL ILL.
ARE YOU DID OKAY O. PUBLIC
COMMENT I'M SORRY.
DO YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.
CATHOLIC HOME IT IS CLOSED
BRITISH TO HOLD OPEN SCHOOL THIS
ITEM OPEN.
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER TEN.
THE CALIFORNIA WORK FIRST
DEVELOPMENT BOARD CALIFORNIA
GLOBAL WARMING SOLUTIONS ACT. SO
JAMAICA BUT WITH THERE WAS ONE
MORE IN A LEGISLATIVE BILL I
DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED TO. TALK
ABOUT IT BUT THERE WAS AN S. B.
THREE OH SIX THE WHOLE TOGETHER
OKAY BUT THEY WERE ALL INTO THE
SAME THING SO I JUST I WE. WE
BROKE OUT BUT THIS IS
LEGISLATION STRENGTHENING ANTI
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS.
IT BIT DOES IT HAVE TO THE
POWERS OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
TO DO CERTAIN THINGS
SPECIFICALLY TO BE ABLE TO ISSUE
CITATIONS IN CERTAIN INSTANCES
RATHER GOING TO THE COURTS WHICH
TEND TO BE SLOWER.
A AND SO WE CAN NOW ISSUE
CITATIONS WHEN WE FIND
RETALIATION.
IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO PROCEED
WITHOUT A WORKER COMPLAINT IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES THOSE ARE VERY
NARROW INSTANCES IN WHICH IT'S
VERY LIKELY THAT WE WOULD OF
SEEN THE RETALIATION FIRSTHAND.
FOR EXAMPLE WORKER COMES TO FILE
A WAGE CLAIM AND EMPLOYER IN OUR
OFFICE MAY SAY SOMETHING LIKE I
CAN'T WE FIND A WAY TO CLAIM TO
HAVE BE DEPORTED.
OR YOU CAN BEFALL THE WAGE
CLAIM YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
FIRED BECAUSE OF IT.
AND ORDERING A FIELD
INVESTIGATION WHERE WE WE
SOMETIMES SEE THE RETALIATION
ALSO OR FOR IMMIGRATION BASED
RETALIATION SO WE CAN IN. IT UP
PROCEED WITHOUT A COMPLAINT
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES THOSE
INSTANCES THE WORKERS ARE SO
VULNERABLE AND SO AFRAID AFTER
THE THREATEN THAT THEY THEY WILL
FILE ONE. OF IT ALSO ALLOWS US
TO SEE GET YARO IN PARTICULAR
INSTANCES SO IT'S THAT REQUEST
FOR STAFFING IN ORDER TO ENFORCE
THOSE PROVISIONS. THAT YOU LL.
FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY WILL SMOOVE ON THAT STILL
WRITTEN DIGITAL THAT OPEN AND
YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
I'M DAN ROUNDS CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
POLICY DIRECTOR THE FIRST ITEM
IS A REQUEST FOR A FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
INCLUDED IN AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT THE CAP AND TRADE
EXTENSION.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. TO ENGAGE WITH
SPECIFIED STAKEHOLDERS TO
PRODUCE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN ON THE NEED FOR
TRAINING EDUCATION. AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
TO HELP THE STATE TRANSITION.
DUE TO CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY
RELATED TO STATEWIDE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS GOALS
BUT THE LOT.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD MUST CONTRACT
WITH SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
PRODUCE THE LEGISLATIVE REPORT.
COMPLETION OF THE REPORT
REQUIRES EXPERTISE IN LABOR
ECONOMICS STATE CLIMATE POLICIES
AND REGULATORY PROCESSES AS WELL
AS THE ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRIES. AND IS BEYOND THE
CAPACITY OF THE STATE BOARD
STAFF TO PRODUCE. THANK YOU LL.
FINANCE.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ALL THIS
ITEM OPENS WILL HOLD OPEN.
NEXT I WAS ISSUED NUMBER ELEVEN.
SECOND ITEM IS FOR APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT SIX POSITIONS RELATED
TO THE FURTHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
WE OWE OUR. THE WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY ACT
INCLUDING MODIFICATIONS TO THAT
WE OWE A STATE PLAN IN SUPPORT
OF THE STATE'S GOAL OF PRODUCING
ONE MILLION INDUSTRY VALUED
CREDENTIALS. OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS STATE BOARD IS EXPANDING
THE REACH REACH THE REACH OF THE
WE HAVE A STATE PLAN. BY ADDING
PARTNERS AND PROGRAMS RELEVANT
TO SPECIFIC POPULATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE ALIGNMENT OF THESE
PROGRAMS WITH THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE SYSTEM AND ULTIMATELY
BETTER SERVE THESE POPULATIONS
THE STATE BOARD HAS ENTERED
INTO.
A COMPREHENSIVE PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS.
KELPIE I A.
TO INTEGRATE A LINE AND
COORDINATE PRE RELEASE EDUCATION
AND PRISONER TRAINING
INITIATIVES WITH POST RELEASE
REENTRY AND WORK FOR SERVICES.
AND FORTY FIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AREAS AND FOURTEEN
WORKFORCE REGION STATEWIDE.
ADDITIONALLY STATE BORDERS
ENTERED INTO A PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE CAL
FRESH IMPLEMENT IN TRAINING
PROGRAM AND LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD IS
ENTERED INTO ANOTHER PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES TO
COORDINATE THE PROVISION. OF
WORKFORCE SERVICES FOR THE
STATE'S UNEMPLOYED NONCUSTODIAL
PARENT POPULATION.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
WELL.
FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS DELUDE
SADDAM OPEN LAW WOULD OPEN.
LAST AUTUMN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
THE THIRD ITEM IS THE PRISON TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE AND
RELATED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THIS PROPOSAL CONTAINS FUNDING
TO FACILITATE THE SYSTEMATIC.
ALIGNMENT IN COORDINATION OF THE
PRE RELEASE
REHABILITATIVE RE ENTRY TRAINING
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS OPERATED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND CAL PIAA. WITH POST RELEASE
REENTRY AND WORK FOR SERVICES
OFFERED IN THE STATE'S FOURTEEN
WORKFORCE REGION'S.
THE FUNDING IS FOR STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S PAROLE
PROBATION AND RE ENTRY SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE REGIONAL PLANS.
TO ALIGN RELEVANT PRE RELEASE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING WITH
POST RELEASE WORKFORCE EDUCATION
AND REENTRY SERVICES. OFFERED TO
THOSE RE ENTERING OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
ALL RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS BE
CONVENED TO DEVELOP THESE
REGIONAL PLANTS SO THAT
APPROPRIATE REFERRALS BE MADE TO
ENSURE. THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN
BOTH ACCESS RELEVANT SERVICES
AND NAVIGATE BETWEEN PROGRAMS AS
THEY REENTER SOCIETY AND ENTER
THE JOB MARKET.
THE FUNDING FOR THE PRISON TO
THE PLANET THEY EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVES FOR PLANNING
ACTIVITIES IMPLEMENTATION OF
REGIONAL PLANS DIRECT SERVICES.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND EARN AND
LEARN ACTIVITIES.
THERE ARE THREE POTS OF MONEY.
THE FIRST IS THE SMALLEST ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION IS FOR
THE CONVENING OF STAKEHOLDERS
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF REGIONAL
PLANS TO ALIGN. COORDINATE AND
INTEGRATE REENTRY AND WORK FOR
SERVICES.
THE SECOND IS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF REGIONAL PLANS
AND THE PROVISION OF DIRECT
WORKFORCE AND EDUCATION
SERVICES.
MISS PART OF MONIES FOURTEEN
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS.
THE THIRD PART OF MONEY IS
TWENTY MILLION AND IS SET ASIDE
FOR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND EARN
AND LEARN ACTIVITIES.
ALL THREE POTS OF MONEY ARE
DESIGNED TO WORK IN CONCERT.
ESTABLISHING A COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED POST RELEASE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORTS
TO HELP TRANSITION THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO HELPING
THEM TO SECURE EMPLOYMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ESPECIALLY ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THE INITIATIVE IS DESIGNED
AND INTENDED TO ROLL OUT HOW THE
POTS OF MONEY WORK TOGETHER. AND
HOW THE INITIATIVE FITS WITH THE
BOARD'S BROADER POLICY EFFORTS
UNDER THE STATE PLAN.
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH THE DOCTOR
CHOI HAS JOINED US ITEM NUMBER
QUESTIONS. OF THE STAFF ANALYSIS
MENTIONS AB ELEVEN ELEVEN FROM
LAST YEAR.
AND ELIO MENTIONS A PREVIOUS
PROGRAM WE REVIEW IS STILL
PENDING.
SO THERE ARE THOSE WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THE REVIEW.
SO THE LEGISLATIVE REPORT IS IN
THE FINAL REVIEW PROCESS THAT
LEVER AGENCY AND IT SHOULD BE
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE NEXT TWO
TO THREE WEEKS.
OKAY HOUSES PER PROGRAM PROPOSAL
DIFFERENT.
FROM THE FORD FOCUS PROGRAM.
IT'S SUBSTANTIALLY DIFFERENT
IT'S SO BOTH PROGRAMS ARE
INTENDED.
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE SAME
POPULATION.
BUT THE FORWARD FOCUS PROGRAM IS
A SMALL GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE FORD FOCUS
PROGRAM THAT WOULD LEAD TO.
SYSTEMATIC COMPREHENSIVE
REGIONAL INTER.
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM. AND THE WORK
FORCE SYSTEM SO RIGHT NOW THE
STATE SPENDS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING.
BUT TWO THIRDS OF THAT IS PRE
RELEASE WITH A ANOTHER THIRD OF
THAT IS POST RELEASE.
THE STATE ALSO SPENDS FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
FEDERAL WORKFORCE MONEY THOSE
TWO.
POTS OF MONEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
OPERATING AS SILOS.
OUR PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO THE FOURTEEN WORKFORCE
REGION'S TO GET THOSE SYSTEMS TO
WORK TOGETHER. COLLABORATIVELY.
NO FORWARD FOCUS PROGRAM.
OUR SMALL GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SOME OF
WHOM.
PARTNER WITH LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S BUT THE
SCALE OF WHAT IS ACHIEVED UNDER
THAT IS VERY DIFFERENT.
SO HOW THE DIFFERENT FOR MAYBE
I'LL WANNA LET ALONE ELEVEN
EIGHTY ELEVEN ELEVEN IS ANOTHER
GRANT PROGRAM THAT IS DESIGNED
TO FOSTER RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S. THE SCOPE OF THAT GRANT
PROGRAM IS FAR BROADER THERE'S
FIFTEEN TARGET POPULATIONS UNDER
THE AB ELEVEN ELEVEN PROGRAM
IT'S IT IT'S JUST WE WHEN WE
WERE PUTTINGTHIS PROPOSAL
TOGETHER. FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE LOOK VERY CLOSELY AT
BOTH OF THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE APPROPRIATE VEHICLES. TO
MEET THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOALS
OF BRINGING THE CORRECTIONS
SYSTEM AND THE WORKFORCE SYSTEM
TOGETHER IT WAS DETERMINED THAT
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS OF.
THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE OBJECTIVES
OF THIS INITIATIVE FACILITIES
PROGRAMS CROSSOVER. QUITE A BIT.
AND MAY BE SOMEWHAT REDUNDANT.
THEY'RE NOT REDUNDANT IN THAT
THE STE THAT A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION GRANT PROGRAMS OR
SMALL PROGRAMS.
THE GRANTS TECH TENDER THEY
RANGE FROM LIKE A HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGE GRANTS OUT TO THE FOURTEEN
REGION'S TO GET TO
SYSTEMATICALLY INTEGRATE WORK
FOR SERVICES WITH PRE RELEASE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING. SO I
KNOW THE LA WAS WRITTEN UP A
BRIEF ON THIS I WANT TO DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION.
TO A BRIEF THE DELEO ISSUED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN. CALLED
ENHANCING PUBLIC SAFETY BY
INCREASING PAROLEE EMPLOYMENT.
AND THAT REPORT THE LA THOUGH
FOCUSED ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
SENATE HEARING WHAT WANT TO HOLD
OFF ON A GOOD REALLY.
FIRST ACTUALLY.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAT
DOWNLOAD THAT WHAT'S ANALYST'S
OFFICE JUST YESTERDAY REALLY WE
RELEASE S. ANALYSIS AND TO
SUMMARIZE VERY BRIEFLY FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE POINT OUT THAT THE
LOGIC OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO US MAKE SENSE.
INTEGRATE SERVICES OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL BETWEEN CORRECTIONS AND
WORKFORCE SPORTS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
AN EFFORT TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICES THAT EX OFFENDERS
RECEIVE.
HELPS THEM FIND AND MAINTAIN
STABLE EMPLOYMENT WITH THE HOPE
THAT THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM
RECEIPT OF IT. TO LOGIC MAKES
SENSE
IN THE COURSE OF OUR ANALYSIS WE
DID UNCOVER THAT. THERE ARE SOME
STRIKING SIMILARITIES TO IN
PARTICULAR AB TWENTY SIXTY ARMY
SEEMS LIKE MUCH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WAS BASED ON
ON THAT PROPOSED PROVISIONS AND
THE EXPERIENCE OF THOSE GRANTEES
HAVE HAD.
AND SO WHEN WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
IT SEEMED AS THOUGH AB TWENTY
SIXTY AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WERE SO SIMILAR. THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD REALLY
BENEFIT FROM HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW. THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT ON
THAT THE STATE BOARD OF
PREPARING AND WILL SUBMIT
SHORTLY BEFORE DECIDING WHETHER
TO. NOTABLY INCREASE AND
VESTMENTS IN WORKFORCE SERVICES
FOR EX OFFENDERS.
FINANCE.
WE JUST
I'D WISH TO REITERATE SUPPORT
FOR THIS.
FOR THIS INITIATIVE THIS
INITIATIVE PROVIDES TARGETED IN
CONFERENCE SUPPORT FOR THE
EXAMINER POPULATION.
A QUESTION OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M WILL HEAD UP A PUBLIC
COMMENT ASIDE AND EMOTION SPEAK.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE. CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION AT THE
OUTSET I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
WE ARE IN NO WAY.
SEEKING TO DETRACT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. BUT WE WANT
TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN WHICH YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
LAYS OUT THAT THIS LEGISLATION
WAS.
NEARLY I WAS BACKED BY A NEAR
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF BOTH HOUSES OF
THE LEGISLATURE. AND IN ADDITION
TO.
PRISON POPULATIONS
I IT IDENTIFIES FIFTEEN UP
FOURTEEN OTHER POPULATIONS
INCLUDING YOUTH WHO ARE
DISCONNECTED FROM THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM MORE EMPLOYMENT. WOMEN
SEEKING TRAINING ARE OR
EDUCATION TO MOVE INTO
NONTRADITIONAL FIELDS OF
EMPLOYMENT PERSONS FOR WHOM
ENGLISH IS NOT A PRIMARY
LANGUAGE. ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED PERSONS VETERANS
NATIVE AMERICANS MIGRANTS OUR
SEASONAL FARM WORKERS PERSONS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
OR OTHER DISABILITIES.
IMMIGRANTS AND PERSONS OVER OVER
FIFTY SO WE WOULD ASK.
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
TO.
CONSIDER.
FUNDING A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN A
MEASURE THAT WAS AGAIN PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE. LAST YEAR AND.
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
I HAD A NOT JUST IN TERMS OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM DATA FOR FY.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SHOWS A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT OF A DOLLARS SEVENTY
ONE FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT
NATIONALLY WITH LOCAL LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SEEKING A SITTING US AND HIGHER
RETURNS IN BEING ABLE TO EXPAND
THE BENEFITS TO THESE
POPULATIONS AYE WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT AND WOULD RESULT IN
THE STATE GETTING MORE THAN ITS
MONEY'S WORTH IN GETTING AT. A
GOOD RETURN ON ITS INVESTMENT
AND SO WE'D ASK AS YOU'D A
DELIBERATE THE BUDGET THAT YOU
CONSIDER EXPANDING THE FUNDING
AND WE'VE REQUESTED A. ARE
AUGMENTED OR A FUNDING FOR THE
FOR A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS HAS IDEAS ON
HOW THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
VERY HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE UC GENERAL.
PLANS HERE TO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
REALLY RECIDIVISM IN THE STATE
PRISONS THE BUILDING TRADES HAVE
BEEN PARTNERS. AND HAVE BEEN
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ASSIST
INMATES ARE BOTH AT THE P. AYE A
AND CDC ARE. THROUGH THE CALPE
AYE A PROGRAM PROVOKE ADD AS
WELL AS THE INMATE WORK LABOR
PROGRAM. WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
THE STATE IN THIS LEGISLATURE TO
ALIGN THE SYSTEM AS IT RELATES
TO BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES A PARTNERSHIP PREPARATION
PROGRAMS.
I THINK SOME OF YOUR COMMENTS
CAN ABOUT LINE THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO NAVIGATE
WITHIN ALL OF THAT AND COMBINE
THEM. SO THAT THERE'S ONE
CURRICULUM THAT WILL HELP ALL
PRE APPRENTICES ENTER THE
APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM. WHICH
SHOT WE ARE VERY PROUD OF IN THE
STATE HAVE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
APPRENTICES.
RIGHT NOW THIS LET THAT THIS
LEGISLATION THIS TRAILER BILL
HAS THAT DIRECTION WE BELIEVE IT
GO A LITTLE BIT FURTHER BY
INCORPORATING THE MC THREE
CURRICULUM WHICH IS THE STATE
CURRICULUM THAT LEADS TO ALL THE
PRE PARTNERSHIP MEAN THE
OPPRESSION PERMITS IN THE STATE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AGENCY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND YOURSELF
AS WELL TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
THANK YOU.
IN A REPORT COMING OUT IN THE
NEXT MONTH OR SO STUFF BY REASON
RECIDIVISM AT ALL HER DRESS
THAT.
NO IT DOESN'T.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT LOOKS SAID
THE THE PLACEMENT RATES IN THE
WAGES FOR FOLKS WHO WENT THROUGH
THE PROGRAM'S AND KIND OF BREAKS
THEM OUT BY THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
THAT THEY HAD? TALKS ABOUT
PROMISING PRACTICES THAT WE'VE
KIND OF ON EARTH THROUGH.
INTERACTING WITH THE GRANTEES.
WE ASSEMBLE THEM A THREE FOUR
TIMES A YEAR TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
PROMISING PRACTICES ARE IN
THESE.
BECAUSE I'M LEARNING
COMMUNITIES.
SO THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION
AROUND YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
ASPECTS OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MORE PROMISING.
THAN OTHER PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
FOUND ON FROM TALKING TO
GRANTEES IS VERY IMPORTANT HAVE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE TABLE
WHEN WE'RE IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS ON DE INVOLVEMENT OF
PROBATION OFFICERS ON IN DOING
SOME OF THE CASE MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
PINSCHERS BETTER OUTCOMES AND
SO.
IN DESIGNING THE PRISON TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE WE'VE
TRIED TO LEARN FROM THOSE SMALL
GRANTS AND AND IN DEVELOPING A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH SO.
IT IS SIMILAR IN THAT THE THE
PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT MISSION OF
HAS A LOT OF THE SAME OBJECTIVES
OF TWENTY SIXTY. BUT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IT'S MORE
SKILLED UP IT'S LIKE.
IT'S LIKE GOING FROM YOU KNOW OF
OF YOU KNOW LIKE A FOUR CYLINDER
CAR TO THE JEEP. DOESN'T MEASURE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
IT LOOKS AT THE RATES OF
EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO GO
THROUGH THE PROGRAM. BASED ON.
THE LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT THEY
GOT SO DOESN'T LOOK AT
RECIDIVISM DIRECTLY THE ORIGINAL
BOND LANGUAGE IN AB TWENTY SIXTY
DOESN'T ASK US TO LOOK AT
RECIDIVISM Y. MINNESOTA
RESPONSIVE TO THE STATUTORY
MENTAL THERE'S A MEASURE OF
EFFECTIVENESS. YEAH ISN'T IT
WHEN LOGS PROBLEMS WE SEE WE
REALLY DON'T SEE MEASURES ARE
METRICS AND DEVELOP PROGRAMS
THAT A LOT OF GOOD PROGRAMS OUT
THERE. AND WHAT A HORRIBLE
PROGRAMS OUT THERE IF FOR SOME
THESE COMMUNITY GROUPS IT'S A
MONEY GRAB. RIGHT SO JUST YOU
KNOW PEOPLE OUT THERE APPLYING
IT JUST THOUGHT I'D IS THIS'LL
WORK THIS THE WORK I MEAN ONE
PROGRAM THEY HAD. WAS WAS ROCK
CLIMBING AND I'M NOT REALLY SURE
HOW ROCK CLIMBING. EQUATES TO
YOU KNOW KEEPING SOMEONE AT OUR
JAILS ARE PRISON SERVING A REAL
BILL TAKING THEM SO.
LIKE SAID IS A HODGE PODGE
PROGRAMS THAT'S ONE THING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HASN'T DONE A
GOOD JOB THAT IS LOOKING GET. IN
DEPTH MORE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS OUT THERE AND YOU KNOW
COPPING THOSE WE WE'VE NOT SEEN
THAT HAS PLAGUED. THE BIGGEST
ISSUE IN FINDING OUT KNOW WHAT'S
EFFECTIVE AND WHAT'S NOT.
WE'VE BEEN INTO THIS I MEAN
THEY'RE STILL GRANTS GOING ON.
WHERE THIS QUITE A BIT YOU KNOW
SORT OF AB ONE I FELT A NUMBER
OF YEARS A LOT OF MONEY'S BEEN
THROWN? AND YOU KNOW WHAT SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE NEVER SEEN.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES
ARE MONO LEGAL MY MEMBERS I
TALKED TO IF NOT SEEN THOSE BEST
PRACTICES AND THAT'S.
AS WITHIN LACKING SO A QUESTION
FOR YOU HOW COME THERE'S AN AT
BCP. TO ACT A. B. ELEVEN OF
ELEVEN ELEVEN.
WHY ISN'T THERE BCP DOING ACT A.
B. ELEVEN ELEVEN YEAH I'M I
DON'T KNOW?
ASKED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THAT.
DIRECTLY WITH THE PART OF
FINANCE.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE SOME
OF WHAT MR ROUND SAID ABOUT THE
VERY TARGETED NATURE OF OTHER
PRISON DEPLOYMENT INITIATIVE
AND.
TO HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING YOU
DECIDE MISTER COOPER INSTEAD OF
HAVING SORT OF HODGE PODGE
DOLLARS SPENT THAT WE WOULD
REALLY LOOK AT WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ON THE GROUND AND THAT WE
WOULD. BE ABLE TO CREATE A FREE
WELL FOR A LOT OF THE FRAMEWORK
IS ALREADY THERE BUT TO THAT
ENHANCE. THE REGIONAL LOCAL
PLANNING.
THAT'S ARE HAPPENING SO THAT'S.
THAT YOU KNOW SHOULD OF.
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING AT THIS
POINT IS VERY TARGETED AND IT IS
A PRIORITY OF THE THE GOVERNOR.
IT WAS STILL GOES BACK TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION THAT WE.
REALLY DON'T HAVE AN EFFECTIVE
MEASURE OF FOCUS SAID A LOT OF
MONEY BESIDES.
ELEVEN ELEVEN ADDRESS THESE AND.
BILLS AND PROGRAMS AND GRANTS.
I MEAN NOTICES HERE AND TELL ME
DEFINITIVELY WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT VISIT OR THE
LEGISLATIVE REPORT WILL ANSWER
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT IN THE TRAILER
BILL FOR THIS INITIATIVE.
THERE'S VERY ROBUST LANGUAGE
AROUND EVALUATION ASSESSMENT OF
THE PROGRAM'S THE OTHER THING
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
TO THE COMMITTEE IS THE.
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT WITH WITH
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS.
THERE'S BEEN INCORPORATED INTO
THE STATE PLAN.
FORESEES THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTION SHARING INFORMATION
WITH THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARDING ET DE SO THAT WE CAN
TRACK INDIVIDUALS INTO THE LABOR
MARKET. NAM AND MEASURE WHICH
PROGRAMS WHICH PRE RELEASE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS ARE
HAVING THE MOST SUCCESS IN
HELPING SECURE PEOPLE. ON JOBS
IN THAT SO I I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH A
COPY OF THAT WORKFORCE
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT. WE SHARE
YOUR CONCERN WITH EVALUATION
ASSESSMENT OF PROGRAMS AND AND
HAVE A WORK PLAN FOR INSURING
THAT THAT WE HAVE GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING AND WHICH ONES ARE
STILL ONLY ASSESSMENT BEGIN.
WHEN WILL THE ASSESSMENT BEGIN.
SO THE ASSESSMENT FOR THIS
PROGRAM IS CONTINGENT ON THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDING THE PROGRAM.
ON IN THE TRAILER BILL THERE'S
LANGUAGE IT SPELLS OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MEASURE THE OUTCOMES.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS IN FACT I
HAD STAFF MEETING WITH
CORRECTIONS STAFF OVER THE LAST
TWO WEEKS
TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
SHARE DATA ACROSS PROGRAMS TO
TO TRACK THEM INTO THE LABOR
MARKET WOULD WAIT WE WILL
PROBABLY GET DATA THAT LIKE WITH
THE DUE DATE ASSURING AGREEMENT.
WILL HAVE WILL WILL PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
OUTCOMES SOMETIME NEXT YEAR.
NEST WITH MY BIG ISSUE IS
OUTCOMES AND I'M JUST BEING THE
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE I HAVE A
HARD TIME GOING FORWARD WITH
ITEMS. WE OUTCOMES ARE KNOWN
JUST GIVING MONEY AWAY.
TO PROGRAMS I'M ALL FOR
REHABILITATION BUT WE'VE DONE A
LOT I GUESS IF YOU GO BACK TO AB
ONE ONLINE IN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETY THOUSAND AND. PROP 47-57
IN A MYRIAD OF BILLS THAT COME
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
DONE A LOT. INFILL LOT OF
TAXPAYER MONEY THESE PROGRAMS
AND YOU KNOW IS THE CLERK POURED
THE OTHER DAY THE RECIDIVISM
RATE WAS. CLOSE FIFTY PERCENT.
AND THAT'S JUST AT THE ON THE
STATE LEVEL HAS NOT LOOKING AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL AND THERE'S NO
METRICS FOR THAT AND AS WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW. MOST FOLKS NAY RE
OFFEND THEY DON'T GO BACK TO
STATE PRISON THEY GO TO COUNTY
JAILS.
UNLESS YOU GUYS WERE THAT MOSTLY
OFFENDERS GO TO COUNTY JAIL. AND
NO ONE IN THE STATE CAN TELL ME
WHAT THOSE NUMBERS ARE FIGURES
ARE SO THERE'S A LOT OF. A GRAY
AREA HERE THAT WE WANT TO GET TO
AND. YOU KNOW I'M GONNA HOLD
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE WITH THOSE
NUMBERS AND NOT JUST WRITE A
BLANK CHECK.
.
BUT SO THIS POINT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
TODAY THAT INCLUDES OUR HEARING
WE BACK NEXT WEEK